[Musica]
che cos'è che qualifica che cos'è che
rende importanti cos'è che dà valore
alle nostre relazioni d'amore alle
relazioni sessuali
quello che cerchiamo nel rapporto fra
genitori e figli
se lo è chiesto la ricerca molto
interessante quello che è emerso è
questo quello che noi cerchiamo e
uguaglianza nei diritti e nella
responsabilità dialogo e assenza di
potere arbitrario assenza di violenza ma
a pensarci bene questo tipo di valori
non sono altro che i valori fondanti
della democrazia
anche la democrazia il vivere
democratico al di là di quelli che sono
i rituali della democrazia
rappresentativa si organizza intorno a
questo tipo di valori qui tanto che
potremmo parlare di democrazia e gli
affetti la vita democratica i valori
della democrazia sono entrati nella
nostra vita di relazione nel nostro
quotidiano nella nostra vita affettiva e
intima molto più di quanto forse non c'è
non ci è sembrato se ci sono questi
requisiti
se c'è dialogo se c'è parità se c'è
rispetto se non c'è violenza non sempre
va così
ma quando non va così stiamo male siamo
scontenti ma quando questi queste
condizioni serie a lizzano la nostra
vita funziona la nostra vita funziona
masse sono anche i requisiti della
democrazia allora funziona anche la
democrazia far funzionare la democrazia
e la conclusione ed è il titolo di un
libro di un famoso ricercatore di
princeton portman il quale dopo
un decennio di ricerche fatte proprio
qui in italia proprio lì mi fa ha
pubblicato un libro far funzionare la
democrazia cos'è che fa funzionare la
democrazia se la democrazia è
collaborazione rispetto interesse per la
vita pubblica quello che fa funzionare
la democrazia sono quell insieme di
valori e li quello che fa funzionare la
democrazia è quello che conta nella
società è quello che rende conto anche
dello sviluppo economico del
dell'efficienza delle amministrazioni
pubbliche delle istituzioni della sanità
della giustizia del sistema scolastico e
quello che ci dà ragione degli alti del
variare dei tassi della criminalità è
quello che ci dà anche ragione del
variare delle condizioni di salute
mentale e fisica della popolazione
e tutto questo lo si può raccogliere
definire con un con con un concetto
capitale sociale
il capitale sociale è una forma di
ricchezza ma è una ricchezza che non sta
nella tasca delle persone ma è qualche
cosa che è in mezzo alle persone che
nella relazione delle persone una
società dove si vive bene è una società
dove c'è un'alta dotazione di capitale
sociale e quindi sviluppo economico
efficienza delle istituzioni bassi tassi
di criminalità e altre condizioni di
salute
quindi una società dove si vive bene e
quindi capitale sociale e felicità
felicità individuali sono legate insieme
la felicità si può misurare mai
misurabile con fattori non quantitativi
non dipende unicamente e non dipende
così proporzionalmente dall'entità del
reddito non contano i beni di consumo
contano i beni relazionali conta un
servizio sanitario efficiente la piena
occupazione
la qualità delle nostre relazioni
personali
la sicurezza la stabilità il problema è
che sicurezza stabilità
piena occupazione sono come dire parole
che non appartengono più a questo tempo
questo sembra essere il tempo nel quale
la felicità è legata a piacere incerti
questo era la pubblicità di una
compagnia telefonica
però però rappresenta lo spirito del
tempo rappresenta il fatto che le nostre
relazioni affettive
i nostri rapporti di lavoro non sono
dati una volta per tutti non sono per
sempre vanno continui possono essere
messi in discussione la nostra vita non
è più definita e non può più contare su
cose stabili ci sentiamo e diventiamo
vulnerabili la precarietà è qualche cosa
che caratterizza la vita dei moderni
naturalmente questo è una parte è un
modo di raccontare la realtà in 15
minuti
la realtà è molto più ricca e molto più
complessa di come me la sto raccontando
io ma questi mi sembrano degli elementi
caratteristici che mi piaceva
presentarvi oggi è anche il futuro è
cambiato le generazioni passate fino a
poco tempo fa i figli sapevano che
sarebbero stati meglio dei loro padri
questo oggi non succede più oggi il
futuro non è più una promessa ma è
diventato una minaccia
e questo non solo per quello che
riguarda le traiettorie di vita
individuale alle cose le nostre cose
personale appunto il lavoro gli affetti
ma anche una visione più globale
l'inquinamento la sovrappopolazione
mondiale tutti quei problemi
la migrazione incontrollata per esempio
sono tutte quelle cose che rendono il
futuro come una terra oscura piena di
nubi minacciose
e allora se il futuro diventa una terra
nella quale meglio non andare
che cosa succede succede che ci rimane
il presente succede che noi ci
ripieghiamo su se stessi
succede che questo può essere definito
come il tempo di narciso acceso ce lo
racconta meravigliosamente nelle
metamorfosi o video si chiude in se
stesso vede solo se stesso il narcisismo
non solo come psicopatologia ma anche
come fenomeno
come narcisismo di massa con me come
fenomeno diffuso e l'attenzione solo ai
propri bisogni preoccuparsi solo di se
stessi in tutti i piani nella vita di
tutti i giorni nella vita lavorativa
l'esempio che vedete dei cowboy della
borsa sono dieci anni proprio adesso che
che ricorda e lo scandalo della lehman
brothers e cioè non importa le
conseguenze di quello che faccio quello
che importa è solo il mio tornaconto
raccontato molto bene dalle tane in
questa vignetta costruire a ricostruire
la propria felicità anche se farlo vuol
dire farlo a discapito a discapito di
qualcun altro
ma se pensare al futuro fare progetti
sognare vuol dire appunto collocarsi in
un futuro che è diventato inospitale
allora dove la cerchiamo la figlia la
felicità e finisce che noi la felicità
la cerchiamo la cerchiamo qui e ci
trasformiamo da cittadini a clienti
cambiamo la nostra prospettiva dal
desiderio che vuol dire proiettarsi nel
futuro vuol dire creare rapporti con gli
altri alle voglie che si soddisfa
soddisfano immediatamente che bruciano
le cose e ma anche le relazioni persino
i rapporti interpersonali
bauman si dice che vengono sottoposti
alla logica del soddisfatti o rimborsati
quando una relazione non mi va più
non c'è tempo per la manutenzione degli
affetti ma si cambia si sostituisce si
passa oltre
e così si delinea il profilo dell'uomo
consumatore e come fatto l'uomo
consumatore eccolo questa un'altra
vignetta di altan che ne che lo racconta
molto bene il consumatore ideale è una
persona che è spinta da spinte primitive
infantile borace volubile sempre in
cerca di nuovi di nuove gratificazioni è
una persona che agisce agisce
d'istinto meglio non pensare meglio non
chiedersi se se se
vale davvero la cosa che stai per
comprare se davvero ti serve non ha i
soldi non importa pagherà in comode rate
comincia a cominciare dall'anno prossimo
l'importante e soddisfare i propri
istinti fai quello che ti senti questa è
la raccomandazione che ci sentiamo fare
sempre più spesso questo spesso il
consiglio che noi diamo ai nostri amici
quando ci chiedono un consiglio anche
sulle decisioni importanti fai quello
che ti senti siamo noi come l'arci zoe
il centro del mondo se va bene a noi
tutto il resto non conta l'importante è
che noi siamo felici ce la raccontiamo
così ma la felicità non è un piacere
solitario la felicità a che fare con
l'abbiamo visto prima a che fare con lo
stare insieme la felicità si costruisce
con gli altri la felicità non è assenza
di regole
la felicità è protetta dalle regole come
la libertà perché ha a che fare con la
libertà
noi quindi pensiamo che la vita emotiva
sia la parte più sincera di noi la più
autentica
la razionalità non serve serve solo a
rallentare a nascondere a mascherare
questo è vero io ma non è davvero
proprio così anche il nostro mondo
interno anche le nostre emozioni anche
il modo col quale noi esprimiamo le
nostre emozioni sottostà ed è
condizionato dalla società da freud a
norbert elias ha tanti ormai sono solo
concetti assodati quindi e la politica e
la politica anche lei sta seguendo la
via del colon
come dice starnone su internazionale
parliamo alla pancia della gente i
politici bravi sono quelli lì quelli che
parlano alle nostre parti basse ad
essere un bel dialogo fra intestino e
intestino siamo siamo in questa logica
qui mobilitiamo le emozioni già questa
cosa non è nuova già i regimi totalitari
del novecento avevano
applicato con metodo questa tecnica ma
anche le democrazie moderne
i nuovi nazionalismi populismi si
muovono secondo questa logica qui è
questo poi porta a una semplificazione
anche del del dibattito politico
noi ci muoviamo secondo la logica un po
da tifosi del calcio
giusto o sbagliato noi loro buoni
cattivi bene male la razionalità e lenta
di discorsi approfonditi non c'è tempo
non ci piacciono e meglio è meglio
imboccare appunto quella che è la via
del colon e le istituzioni poi finiscono
la politica poi finisce per passare da
interessarsi del bene comune da
interessarsi del futuro alla alle
felicità individuali del qui ed oggi poi
le conseguenze poi debiti qualcuno li
pagherà sun mangeranno quelli che
vengono dopo
qui c'è una citazione di di euripide che
dai greci avevano già capito tutto sulla
democrazia sui rischi della democrazia
e poi naturalmente se noi seguiamo
questa via la via della bassa emotività
dell'impulso vita
finiamo per sostituire l'empatia la
carità e la pietà ai diritti anche nei
nostri comportamenti d'acquisto non
sempre ci rendiamo conto che quando
acquistiamo dei voli a basso costo
quando acquistiamo delle merci che
costano poco
lo scambio è sempre una cessione di
diritti
dietro c'è sempre gente che ha perso dei
diritti e che lavora senza le garanzie
che ci sono sempre state e che hanno
sempre protetto le persone che lavorano
questo è una forse del degli aspetti
della delle rimozioni che noi mettiamo
in atto
e poi c'è quest'altra cosa il rapporto
con noi spesso siamo in siamo in
rapporto col mondo attraverso la
superficie sottile degli schermi dei
nostri televisori dei nostri telefoni
dei computer e il lontano ci appare
prossimo si però senza profondità però
superfici
male dove tutto è uguale zyklon b astag
ai feelgood questo è quello che ha
scritto un gruppo di studentesse che
hanno visitato auschwitz
nello stesso tempo erano tristi per la
tragedia che ha riguardato gli ebrei ma
anche contenti in una schizofrenia
emotiva che non è nuova e non è strana
vuoi provate a guardare la televisione
mentre ci danno la notizia di qualche
delle centinaia di morti di uno tsunami
di un terremoto sotto scuola e la
striscia con i risultati di calcio o con
l'annuncio che sta tra poco ci sarà
l'intervista un famoso comico e allora
siamo siamo appunto in una specie di
scissione di schizofrenia emotiva e
allora cosa fare
e allora è allora quello quello che
dovremmo fare è quello di portare le
emozioni in alto dalla pancia al
cervello
noi non siamo solo emozioni noi siamo
emozioni e cervello
e allora le emozioni si possono
elaborare le emozioni si possono i
comportamenti si possono ricondurre alle
emozioni che le hanno che le hanno
provocate
anche quando a volte questi queste
emozioni questi comportamenti sono
quello che spinosa chiamava le passioni
tristi i sentimenti che si
rimpiccioliscono l'odio il rancore
la rabbia l'invidia e cercavo se devo
dire un esempio con qualche cosa per
chiudere questa conversazione con voi e
ea certo punto mi è arrivata la voce di
una resina non avevo preso negozio e ho
sentito la voce dalla reggina ecuba
delle troiane euripide siamo 2500 anni
fa circa nel 416 decide di raccontare la
guerra in corso la guerra del
peloponneso non attraverso grandi
imprese
l'epica le sfide e i duelli no lui
racconta la guerra dal punto di vista
dei vinti ci racconta che la guerra e
sangue e vendetta e sopraffazione
proprio in questi giorni è stato
assegnato il nobel per la pace
a a due operatori che hanno combattuto e
ha reso pubblico la metodologia dello
stupro di guerra questo è la guerra non
è fatta solo da eroi
e allora c'è questa reggina alla quale
hanno ucciso il marito alla quale hanno
ucciso i figli
questa donna resa schiava ma non
umiliata che rimane grande perché sa
guardare in faccia il dolore questa
donna la quale alla fine i greci per
paura che il figlio di ettore diventasse
grande come il padre per paura che
potesse un giorno vendicare tutto quel
sangue
allora questa donna alla quale portano
questo piccolo corpo un soldato depone
il piccolo corpo accanto a lei così
parla
e così si rivolge ai greci ecco guardate
avete avuto paura di un bambino
questa è la voce della reggina ma la
voce della reggina noi la possiamo forse
sentire ancora tutte le volte che ci
rendiamo conto che ci siamo lasciati
trasportare dalla voce della pancia
invece che da quella integrata da quella
del cervello e credo che ci sia successo
di sentire la voce di questa reggina
quando nello schermo sottile dei nostri
televisori e arrivata questa immagine
ancora una volta un soldato ancora una
volta un piccolo corpo forse anche noi
guardando quella foto abbiamo sentito la
voce della regina e abbiamo capito che
avevamo avuto paura di un bambino
grazie
[Musica]